[音楽]
[拍手]
渡辺ん
暮らし上手は幸せジョーズ
これは私たち株式会社クラシーの30周年記念誌のタイトルです
皆さん
暮らしの価値っていうことを改めてお考えになったこと終わりですか
心の満腹感を与えてくれるおふくろの味
掃除の行き届いた清潔の空間で疲れた心と体を委ねる一時
カーテンから漏れる心地よい朝の日差し
壁には
家族や友人と旅行した時の一年写真の数々
この風景たちが
暮らしの素敵ですよね
優しい時間と空間そしてそれを共有する
家族や友人という仲間が集う場
その場こそが生きる力を育み
あるいは再生する
暮らしの場すなわち家庭です
暮らしあってこその人生仕事暮らしあってこその人生
まずは足元の暮らしを整えなさい
私は母にそう教えられて育ちました
家庭は家族の心の写真
過程こそが
家族の幸せの製造構造工場だと
そんな普通の幸せを意識している暇などない
仕事こそ価値メッシ号広角5
大量生産大量消費大量廃棄
20世紀の香合工業化社会
時代は規模の経済に向けてひた走ってきました
その途中で私たちが置き忘れてきてしまった
生活価値
暮らしの素敵を
もう一度
見直してみませんか
そうすると心にゆとりが再来していい仕事をするためには良い暮らしが必要なんだと
一息つけます
次の時代に柔らかな社会をつなぐため
手を伸ばせば助けてくれる支えてくれる
生活支援サービスインフラがあるまちづくり
このビジョンのもと1986年
今から30年前奇しくも男女雇用機会均等法施行の年に私上田市西湖は
企業いたしました
工業化社会の経済武者たちはこぞって
女性の起業
保育
家事介護だってっ
妻がやったらただのそのアンペイドワークをペイドワークにする
冗談じゃない
非常識極まりないことだ
と一周します
まさしく
逆風トップ吹き荒れる厳しい船出でした
新年と
執念が
そして時代の歩みが
私を支え
すぐ背中をしてくれました
私自身は女性として
暮らしの価値を唱える者として
既存社会の経済常識とやら
度の違いを恐れない勇気を
そして社会にはその違いを否定しない勇気を期待して
既
30年
ようやくですが徳島ね本社を聞い
東名阪の40カ所のサービス拠点から
生活総合支援サービス事業を展開しています
株式会社クラシーは社会起業ソーシャルビジネス
時代の要請として生まれ育ち
新たな高
公として社会のために働く企業だと自負しています
家庭が家族の心の写真なら
地域は
そこに住まう暮らし人の心の写真
その街その町にあった
各5ならぬ多様なサービスを提供することを心がけています
今時代は
加速する少子高齢化
それに伴う
生産年齢人口の減少
進む核家族化という大きい課題を抱えています
私の関心は
その課題により起こる現象
すなわち家庭力の低下
にフォーカスしています
世帯人数
現在は2.49人というこの現実は
求めるものは
主婦力です
ちなみに主婦の二が感じではなくカタカナです
これは男女何が担うにしても家庭を運営する力を収集力と私たちが捉えているからです
のでどうぞそのようにご理解ください
その主婦力はマルチタスク365日
繰り返し繰り返し
家族のためにそそがれる家族愛という心な力です
その主婦力が
つまり生活支援サービスが
人々の暮らしにを紡ぐにために
どんなお手伝いをしているか
ここで少し事例を通して御説明をいたします
例えば子育て層
彼らはとにかく時間不足です
朝は
自分の身支度に子供のみ自作とこお弁当作りを選択をしながら夕食の段取りをしながら
もう戦争です
しつく暇なく一日を過ごす中で
ふと
子供の目を見て話をしていない自分に気がつきます
子供と向き合うためだけの時間がせめて週に1度でもあればとお掃除やお洗濯は家事
サービスを活用することでしのぎ
一時
子どもの話に
こころの耳を傾けます
中高年層といえば心のゆとり不足
孫も見てやりたいでも親の介護も心と気持ちを求められます
とはいえ
地域社会や会社で担う役割周り
なにしろ代わりがいない
出口のないこういった困りごとを抱えるのが
この世代
年末の大掃除や親の病院の付き添い
そして
日常のお買い物など
何かと少しずつ家事サービスの助けを借りることで
心にゆとりを暮らしに笑顔を取り戻そうとします
そして高齢者層
押し寄せるカレーに抗いながらも年々気力体力
の衰えは避けられません
お風呂のお掃除窓拭きお庭のお掃除
特に大きい火事思い火事ほど大変だと感じます
だけど
暮らしの場は整えておかないとせめて3の前のことは
自分で賄わないと
ただでさえ忙しい子どもたちに心配をかけてしまうとかじるサービスを利用することで
不足を補います
日常の喧騒の中
人がしばし錨をおろす港
た体
ここで
明日への活力が醸成されます
何気ない一日が
豊なる日常なんだと
暮らしの価値を大切に思うからこそ
生活支援サービスがある暮らしがスタンダードとなるべき
次の時代に柔らかな社会をつなぐため私は世の中にそんな新たな常識を作りたいと
思うのです
そのためにもこれまで
家族愛をそのエネルギー源として自分の家族に向けて発揮してきた
主婦力をこの後は人間愛に根ざす職業として家庭力が低下した
地域街に向け発揮するまさしく
主婦力の社会化がが必要で
あると私は
考えています
いかがでしょう皆さんご共感いただけますでしょうか
まず暮らしを科学する
家事を細分化し分類し分析する
そして可能な限り
ベースとなる火事行為を
平準化し
額に汗するだけじゃなくて心に汗することができるようなサービス環境を担保する業界
を作り
誰もが
安心して同じ条件でサービスを受けられるよ
サービス基準を定める
さらに妖怪の活性化とともに異業種の参入を促し
産業化を図る
そして
この業界に優秀な人材を獲得する
みなさんこれが急務なんです
だった学生の皆さんが就活を始めるにあたり
よし生活支援サービス業界に就職しよう
で想い+若者に出会った断りですか
おそらくありませんよねそんな行学許容甲斐があるという認識がないからなんです
だから産業化が必要なんです
家庭とは最もプライベートな空間です
いかに一人一人のお客様の家風や価値観や日々の暮らしぶりにお客様が違和感を感じ
られないようにそっと寄り添い
柔軟に巧みに変化対応していくか
普通に考えると非行率そのものしかも相当に講師な心の技を求められます
この新しい概念のサービスをどう作るかどう維持するかそしてどう届けるか
生活支援サービスこれ
無形のサービス形がないんですね
そうなんですがこれに従来あるような製品化商品化と継続安定供給の仕組みと
マーケティングと
そういったビジネスのプロセスを新たな視点と手法と知識と知恵とたい山の努力で構築
していかねばなりません
この暮らしを科学するという取り組みが進むにつれて主夫力の職業科社会科という時代
の要請に応えていくことができるのです
暮らし上手は幸せ上手主婦力は家族愛人間愛の代名詞
私はそれを母の背中からそして母の生き様から学びました
今この時生活価値
暮らしの素敵にどうぞ思いを馳せてください
次の時代に柔らかな社会をつなぐため妻がいつまでこうして元気で甲斐甲斐しく
台所に立っていてくれるんだろうと言い知れない不安にさいなまれる
日々が皆様の近未来のくらしの姿とならぬよう
暮らしを科学し主力の職業科社会科
そしてクラスサービスの産業化を急ぎたいと念じています
皆様
皆様のご関心を私たちにどうぞ
お寄せくださいそしてその力をお貸しください
私たち小さな蔵 c の大きな挑戦は
これからも
続きます
ありがとうございましたん
[拍手]
[音楽]
me